hi I'm Evan Carmichael welcome to an
edition of ask Evan in today's episode
I'm going to answer question for my form
readers dawn wrote in asking about
failures and he said as an entrepreneur
what was your biggest failure online so
thanks for the question dawn I think
there's a lot you can learn from your
own failures but also from the failures
of others and hopefully you don't make
those same mistakes because you can
learn from other people's fails instead
of making them yourself I think the
biggest failure in line for me was when
I had my first real software company was
19 years old we're thinking what kind of
features you want to build in this who
could sell it online to our customers
and one of the things we added in the
most complicated piece in the software
was ability to do undo redo unlimited
time so what that means basically is if
you are making a mistake you can go undo
and you can do undo again and then do
again and this is for Biotechnology
software so it was really complex
software and you wouldn't think the most
complicated thing and that's in the
software was be able to do undo redo a
little bit at times most software
programs even word or Photoshop whatever
you used to we'll only undo a certain
number of times after that you know if
it's 20 times for example then you can't
do any more for our software can do
unlimited so that was such a cool
feature who's going to love this nobody
else does this on the market and as it
turns out nobody cared fortunately had
enough other stuff in our software that
people liked and bought it found really
helpful but the lesson there was we
spend so much time working on this
feature that we thought was really cool
but nobody else cared about and we
didn't take enough time listening to our
customers and pulling them for their
feedback before going out and building
our product so since then that's
probably the biggest failure are made
and luckily again we still had enough
other great things in our software that
people wanted to buy but that was the
most complicated time-consuming thing
that we spent their time on so it could
have been spent a lot more effectively
since then we try to do a lot of
the failure so I remember calm now we
fail a lot we tried tons of new projects
every month and we see what sticks and
what doesn't stick I'm trying things my
team is trying things and we encourage
failure we just try not to fail big we
try to start small in all of our
projects and then slowly build up and up
and up as you see that they're getting
some traction we try not to spend a lot
of money especially the beginning of any
new project a great example since you
guys are watching this video is our
videos if you look back to the early you
know first videos that we did we first
partnered up with the video production
company that didn't cost us money and
then I did them on my own and didn't
have nice gear any lighting any
microphone it was no no staying for the
camera so things were wobbly and the
material was still good but the lighting
was bad and the quality was just really
bad compared to what the videos are now
but we did that because I didn't want to
spend a lot of money starting up a new
project that wasn't going to be
successful so we'll try whole bunch of
those little things and then most of
them fail and then some of them will
take off and do well we'll continue to
invest in them so the videos are one of
those projects that started doing well
and became fine it was a great way to
connect with our community and drive
traffic as well so we kept doing more
and more more than I invested in a
microphone and lighting in the camera a
better camera on a tripod to make the
videos better every time that we do it
but it could have gone nowhere right I
could have spend all this money invest
in all the year and only done two videos
and that's not really how you want to
start project so we learned our lesson
from that big failure you listen to your
customers trying to build around them
and then on going try to fail small try
to fill a lot but fail small and
hopefully you'll get a few ideas most
potential failures that do do well and
you will to build hopefully a really
successful company out for them so
thanks for the question down hope that
answer your question for those of you
watching if you liked the video please
give it a thumbs up and makes me wanna
do more of these videos for you guys and
you give a question about failures or
another question
your business feel free to leave in the
comments below I always read those and I
try to answer as many as I can so thank
you and you'll see you on the neck
deficit
you